in this course you will learn about
popular visual studio code extensions
that can help improve your productivity
hey everyone my name is roman and i'm a
full stack developer and today i'm going
to talk about 10 vs code extensions that
are going to make your life easier as a
developer and also have just made me
more productive below this video is a
list of all 10 of those extensions along
with the places you can go to download
them so let's get started
so the first extension we're going to
talk about is git lens git lens is a vs
code extension that allows you to
visualize git context around files but
also lines of code
you can go ahead and search for git lens
in the vs code extension marketplace and
it will probably be the first search
result that pops up now it's published
by get kraken and if you see that go
ahead and install
and after you're done installing you're
going to want to reload your window for
the extension to take effect right away
for mac you can press command shift p
for windows ctrl shift p
and it's going to open up the command
palette and just type in reload window
and go ahead and reload it
now what you're immediately going to
notice is wherever your cursor is
there's going to be this unobtrusive
annotation
basically it's going to say the git
commit author the git commit date and
the git commit message
and now if you hover that line you're
going to get a better visualization of
all that information
on the bottom left you're going to
notice a git commit number
if you click that you're going to get a
bunch of options
you're going to be able to reveal the
commit in a sidebar you can revert the
commit you can reset the commit and so
on and so forth
in our particular case we're going to
reveal this commit in a sidebar
and what you're going to see is this
tree that shows every commit
and it's already expanded the commit
we're interested in
you can go ahead and interact with this
tree
i'm just going to click the
calendar.view file because it says it
was added
and i can see all the additions that
were made in this file in this
particular case the whole file was added
and now if you're interested in looking
at other commits
you can unexpend this and you you can
expand other commits at will
and if you go up one level you can see
all the things that get lens allows you
to do
it allows you to use source control it
allows you to use this commits view a
file history view you can look at all
your local branches i only have one that
being the main branch you can look at
your remote branches again i only have
one which is
the remote main branch you can look at
git stashes
tags and there's this search and compare
feature where you can search for commits
by message author file etc
now if you go back to this hover menu
what you're going to notice is a globe
icon
what this globe icon allows you to do is
look at your commit in github
before you do this you're going to want
to sync with github in my particular
case i've already done this
it's going to be an icon right here
and what it will do is pull in the
picture of the author from github
and also allow you to click this icon
so i'm going to go ahead and click this
icon
and it's going to show me all the
changes in this commit through github
now we're going to go back
and the final thing i want to show you
is this team option
this allows us to open a live share
session with the author of this commit
in this particular case we haven't quite
installed live share yet
i'll show you how to start sessions and
interact with live share later in this
video
but this is just a handy feature to know
about now at the bottom you're gonna see
this bar blame option
and basically this shows us the last
author on this file along with the last
commit date
and then at the top what we're gonna see
is all the authors on this file in this
case it's just me so it's only showing
me as a singular author but if there's
multiple authors it will show the name
of all the authors along with how many
there are
i often find this really helpful when i
need to tag people on pr's often the
best people to tag on a pr are the ones
have either authored the file
or worked with it before now that's all
the things i'm going to touch on about
git lens in this video if you're
interested in learning more about
different features be sure to look at
the documentation and i hope you find
this useful when you're looking for the
right people to tag on pr's or you're
just trying to visualize get better
during this time when remote work has
become so normalized i've often found it
really hard to collaborate with my peers
vs code liveshare is an extension that
has made collaboration and pair
programming incredibly easier liveshare
is a way for me to host sessions with up
to 30 people where i can debug files
with others pair program and even teach
when i'm using live share i can also
share various resources like a server my
terminal or my file straight through my
session using read and or write
permissions
right now i'm going to hop on a call
with my buddy liam who's going to help
me debug an issue with my calendar app
using vs code liveshare
to kick things off i'm going to click
down here on my name
this is going to open some options it's
going to say start a collaboration
session start read-only collaboration
session or join a collaboration session
in my case i want to start one
and then what i'm going to do is open
this again
and i'm going to copy my link so i can
invite my friend liam to help me with
this bug i've been struggling on
now my friend liam has joined the call
and i'm going to start an audio call
with him so i'm going to go ahead and
click
on that bar down there and start or join
audio call this is going to start up a
call with
liam and he'll be joining shortly
what you're also going to notice in the
meantime is there's this live share chat
the live share chat has also said liam
has joined
uh you could opt to
chat with others through this but
in my case i find it a lot easier to
pair program over a call
hey roman can you hear me hey liam how's
it going it's going well it's going well
i heard you were having calendar
problems
yeah
so there's this problem with this
calendar app i made basically
i just i create an event and after i
create the event it goes on my calendar
but then when i go to delete the event
um it doesn't delete on the first time
around but it deletes on the second time
i try
take me to your calendar
delete function
uh yeah i think that's called delete
event
okay yeah it's on line 156
okay
i think you're gonna want to async await
this calendar service delete event
okay
try saving that and give it a shot all
right i'll try saving that
i'm going to try this out real quick
just to make sure that works
oh cool wow that worked
hey i'm happy to help
awesome thanks
yup
see ya talk later bye see you
and i'm going to go ahead and stop that
collaboration session which is also
going to end the call with liam
and that's the power of vs code
liveshare you can immediately
share your session and your screen with
someone else but also set up an audio
call
and a chat straight in your vs code
editor
pieces is an ai assisted code snippet
manager that auto classifies languages
helps save and reuse code snippets and
allows you to convert screenshots of
code to actual text among many other
things using their vs code extension and
other integrations so to get started
with pieces you can go straight to
code.pieces.op and on the top right you
can see this get pieces button
when you see that go ahead and click it
and it's going to take you to an
installation page for pieces os
which is basically the engine that
powers all integrations in pieces
including the vs code extension
depending on your machine you're going
to want to download for mac or windows
in my case i want to install for mac so
after the initial installation i'm going
to get both pieces os and pieces for
developers
pieces for developers looks like this
and it's just a gui for my code snippets
which i'll touch on a little bit more
later to make the most of my setup
but before we touch on pieces for
developers let's hop into vs code and
install the pieces for vs code extension
so when you go into vs code and type in
pieces
the first result is probably going to be
pieces for vs code if you see this
you're going to go ahead and install and
you're going to immediately see this new
pieces icon upon installation
on the left
so right now i don't have any code
snippets so it's empty
what i'm going to want to do is add a
code snippet
in practice the kind of code snippet i
want to add is something i might reuse a
lot
or something i might reference or maybe
just something i found especially
difficult to write or create
that i want to keep for safekeeping so
let's just say this update range
function fits one of those criteria so
i'm going to go ahead and save that to
pieces with a right click and then save
to pieces
what we're immediately going to see is
there's a new top level directory called
javascript from pieces auto
classification of the snippet
and then if you expand that directory
you can click on the javascript snippet
and you're going to see the update range
function you can also hover the snippet
and it's going to show you a preview of
that function
what i'm going to do now
is delete the update range function in
my calendar.view file
and let's just say you know i'm working
on a project i want to pull in that
update range function all i have to do
is go to my snippet
and press insert snippet
and it saved the way i formatted this
function and also pulled that piece of
code directly into the place i wanted
the snippet to be put in now the last
thing i'm going to want to do is rename
the snippet to something more
appropriate
i'm just going to pick the function name
which is update range
and now it's saved as update range
awesome
just to recap what pieces allows me to
do is store my code easily straight in
my ide
and also gives me the ability to pull
that code out
so now where pieces starts to become
really powerful is when you start using
the other integrations along with vs
code
so what i'm going to do now
is go to stack overflow
and i'm looking at this cohort analysis
sql snippet
now i find this cohort analysis sql
snippet really helpful
and it's also kind of hard to write so i
want to go ahead and save that to pieces
since i have the google chrome extension
what i'm going to see on the top right
is this pieces icon
and this allows me to click the icon and
directly save this code snippet to
pieces without leaving stack overflow
so i'm going to go ahead and click that
and then what i'm going to do instead of
looking in vs code
is open up pieces for developers
what i'm going to see in pieces for
developers is an auto classification of
the sql snippet
which is the cohort analysis i just
showed you and then if i click on this
little information view it's going to
give me more metadata about this
particular snippet
it pulls in the title from stack
overflow as a description
it pulls in the link of the stack
overflow question and opposing the
origin which is a pieces chrome
extension
and depending on what extension or what
integration you save with using pieces
it will have a different origin
now for search i can add tags so i'm
going to add cohort as a tag i'm also
going to add sql as a tag
i'm going to write cohort and sql as a
tag
and this is just generally going to help
me search better using pieces for
developers
and now if we go back to vs code
we can open our pieces explorer and
refresh a tree
and if you expand the sql section you'll
see the sql snippet we just created
which is the cohort
analysis cool
now the second practical use case i
found for pieces integration especially
pieces for developers
is converting
screenshots of code to actual code i can
use
so oftentimes when i'm watching tutorial
videos
i don't want to pause the video or leave
the video because i'm really trying to
understand the subject i'm learning
but i do want to take a piece of code or
copy the piece of code for safe keeping
or i just want to run it locally to test
it out while i'm watching the video
pieces can be really useful for this
so this particular video is a video on
free code camp that just came out for
building a live stream using flutter
i'm going to copy these three lines of
code which is dart
and i'm going to convert that
to code using pieces for developers
so immediately when i drag the
screenshot over to pieces for developers
it identifies it as an image with dart
there's this option to view as code on
the right hand side i'm going to go
ahead and click that
what i get is copyable code
from pieces for developers straight from
the screenshot
and just to show you i'm going to open
up
my ide
i'm going to copy it and you can see i
copied that code straight from pieces
for developers
better comments is a vs code extension
that improves your comments by helping
you annotate and document code more
efficiently using a custom tagging
system after you're done installing
better comment
you're going to want to open up your
command palette
and type in open settings and you're
going to get this json option let's go
ahead and click that
so after we click that we're going to
type better comments
and intellisense is going to kick in and
show this bettercomments.tag
go ahead and pick that
and this is going to show all the
default settings for better comments
so there's a couple tags that come out
of the box for better comments
there's the alert tag using an
exclamation mark there's a question
there's a commenting tag there's a to-do
tag and there's a catch-all tag
and within a tag
there's a color property there's a
strikethrough an underline a background
color a bold and italic property and
each of these can be manipulated
differently
in order to make a unique tag that
anyone can identify in your code system
or can be made for you to read easier
so before we go ahead and dive into code
let's add an additional tag here and
we're going to create a bug tag
and then i'm going to change the color
so we can identify this to some random
color here
go ahead and save this file
and i'm also going to reload my window
again just so this kicks in
cool so that bug tag should show up in
our code
what we're going to do is suppose we
just want to add a comment on line
15
so i want to add a comment saying this
is a bug and it has a race condition so
bug
fix race
condition here
and
now better comments is taking the tag
from the settings.json file and applying
the properties we set over there
immediately what i'll be able to tell
with the use of better comments is that
any pink comment is probably
documentation for a bug
and suppose this race condition is just
you know it's a very big deal and we
want to make sure people know about this
we can switch it to an alert
and it changes to that orangish color
that was set by better comments we can
also look at different tags like a
question mark which is blue
and you could change each of these the
way you want to in our settings.json
file
say you know we had a bug comment
and now we've decided this bug is fixed
but we want to leave the comment in the
code base
we can use the better comments
strikethrough feature and it will just
strike it through without getting rid of
the comment
so essentially what better comments has
done is it's made it easier to visualize
any comments in your code base and if
you're using similar settings or if
everyone on your team is using it now
they're going to be able to associate
different color comments
to different tags and different problems
let's just admit it
we all end up console.logging a bunch
when we're trying to find an error or a
bug and i'd love to say i use a debugger
every time but that's just not the case
and that's where turbo console log comes
into play
turbo console log is basically a vs code
extension that makes logging a lot
easier
you can easily add detailed console.log
messages
delete these messages all at once and
even comment them out altogether
so i'm going to dive in real quick
basically suppose that there is a bug
i'm trying to find on this calendar.view
file
and i want to console.log a few things
that might help me track down this bug
i'm going to go ahead and highlight a
couple variables and i'm going to use
turbo console log
to help me create logging messages for
them
so for this event variable
i'm going to press
control option l
and that will create a logging message
for me on mac
for windows users you're going to do
control alt l
and then i'll pick a couple
more variables i'll do this event here
control option l
i'll do this
type here
control option l
and now we have a couple console.logging
statements
cool this is what a file ends up looking
like and if we look at these console.log
statements what we have is each
console.log message has the file name
the line number associated with the
comment the function
and then the exact variable name
so now suppose
we think we've solved the problem we're
trying to track down and we want to
comment all these lines out to make sure
the code works without getting all that
extra noise
for mac users you want to do option
shift c
and for windows users you want to do alt
shift c so we're going to do option
shift c since i'm on mac
and now we've commented out all lines
the only thing to remember here
or the only thing to know
is that all these keyboard shortcuts i'm
showing you will only work for logging
statements created by turbo console log
if you're creating your own logging
statement
and then also creating some by turbo
console log
these keyboard shortcuts won't work for
the ones you created yourself
now after we've commented all these
console.logging statements we've now
realized that we haven't tracked down
the error
so we want to get these back in action
for mac users you would want to do
option shift u and for windows users you
want to do alt shift u and that will
uncomment all those commented
console.log statements
so the last thing left here is you know
you're done debugging you want to get
rid of all these console.logs
historically the way i usually do this
is i just search for them and get rid of
them through a search but
with turbo console log all you need to
do is press option shift d for mac or
alt shift d for windows
and it will get rid of all
console.logging statements at once
code runner is a vs code extension that
allows you to run code snippets and
files easily with just a highlight and a
right click
so i'm going to go ahead and open this
loop.py file and show you how code
runner works
let's say i have this function in my
code it's called create list and
basically it just creates an array or
list of numbers from 0 through 9.
i'm going to show you how this works
right now i'm just going to print
this list
and use code runner highlight all this
code and just
right click run code
cool it showed me that list
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine
and let's say you know in a practical
scenario i'm looking at this code and
i'm like wow i can actually refactor
this to be a lot better but first i want
to make sure it's being refactored
correctly
so what i'm going to do is make my
refactor my refactor is a list
comprehension so i'm going to say i for
i in range 10
and let's just make sure this is
returning the same thing as our final
variable over here
i'm going to go ahead and highlight this
again real quick
run code
i see the same result for both
so now all i'm going to do is
take my refactored code put it in the
return value and get rid of all this
extraneous code
and as easy as that i made the refactor
and now i know it works and hopefully
after this i tested against my tests and
that also confirmed it works but i've
often just found code runner really
helpful when i'm trying to make these
quick refactors and get an immediate
response on whether this change is
working or not
as developers we know the importance of
fast applications and websites and one
of the things that affects performance
is the size of your bundles
now
a slow application or website can lead
to lower seo rankings more users
bouncing off your websites or
applications and just generally a bad
user experience so that's where import
cost comes into play import cost forces
you to look at the size of your
third-party javascript packages straight
in your editor and you can fix any large
imports right away so after you've
installed import cost go ahead and open
a js file
in my case i have this main.js file with
a couple third-party imports
what i immediately notice is lowdash is
my largest package but i'm only taking
this for each function
so how can i make this smaller
i can make this smaller by maybe
just deconstructing
no that doesn't exactly work
um
import cost says it hasn't really made a
difference in the size of the package
i'm importing well let's use a sub
module to just grab this for each
function
and there we go
now it's down to 5.7 kilobytes and in
real time import cost tells me
that i have made my bundle smaller and
this just instills best practices so
when you're pushing up a new application
or when you're pushing up a new website
you're making sure your third-party
packages are not bloating your bundle
now prettier is an opinionated code
formatter for various web development
languages such as javascript typescript
jsx etc my prettier setup in a way where
it formats all javascript files upon it
being saved which is just a huge
convenience because it enforces code
styling that i've customized through my
own settings
now there's two caveats to prettier the
first caveat being that if you don't
like your code being rewritten which is
essentially what prettier does with its
automated code formatting you might not
like it so much it can be often really
difficult to set up with a linter but
once you get it set up it could be
great in conjunction with eslint which
is the next extension we'll talk about
to start off we're going to look at
prettier settings which will dictate how
prettier will format its own files
so on mac you're going to do command
comma
on windows you're going to do control
comma
and you can type in prettier
and it's going to open all the prettier
related settings
there's a setting for arrow functions
there's a setting for bracket spacing
and so on and so forth
i'm just going to go with the default
settings for the sake of this video but
if you're inclined to use a customized
settings file or you want some sort of
customization so your prettier doesn't
overwrite some styling that you're used
to you can go ahead and customize your
prettier what we're going to want to do
next is search for format on save up
here
and you want to make sure this box is
checked
what it's essentially going to allow you
to do
is format the file
on save using your prettier settings
now the last thing i want to touch on
before i show you a demo of prettier
is that
sometimes i've struggled to set up
prettier because another extension
conflicts with it in my case the
extension was beater a view extension
and i had to set it up in a way to let
that extension know that prettier is
going to be the default formatter
so i'm going to show you how i did that
i'm going to open my settings.json file
and essentially what i did is there's
some vendor settings that sets a default
formatter
for all the files that i want prettier
to format
i just specify that prettier is the
default formatted for that file not veda
so what you want to go ahead and do
is if you find that your printer is not
working
you should check if any of the other
extensions you have are conflicting with
it
so the last thing i'm going to do over
here is pop open this calendar.view file
and i have a bunch of poorly formatted
code
i want to format this properly according
to the settings i have my prettier
configurations i'm going to go ahead and
save this file
and printer automatically enforces all
of its styling
as you can see it's pretty seamless and
is often used in conjunction with the
linter eslint which is going to be the
next extension we're going to talk about
the eslint package is a linter and
formatter that statically analyzes
javascript code to find problems
these problems can be both stylistic and
coding ones
some of the coding ones are stuff like
a missing variable name or using a let
where a const makes more sense now in
this video we'll be talking about the
eslint extension mostly which works with
the eslint package to help you visualize
linting errors along with suggestions on
how to fix them and the vs code
extension for eslint gives you quick
fixes directly in the editor which are
super helpful in picking up mistakes or
poorly written code in real time
so to get started we'll have to make
sure our project has eslint first and we
also have to make sure that the eslint
package is installed globally
to do so you can go ahead and run this
command over here which is npm install
dash g eslint to install it globally
and then in my case i already have it
installed globally so i'm going to go to
the next step which is bootstrapping my
project with eslint
so after it's installed globally go
ahead and type in eslint dash init
and you're going to be prompted with how
to set up eslint for your project
in my case i want the full capabilities
of eslint so i want to check it for
syntax find problems and enforce code
styles
and then my modules are javascript
modules
the framework i'm using for the calendar
app is
vue.js
my project does not have typescript
it's running in the browser
and i want to go ahead and use a popular
style guide if you want to answer
questions about your style you can go
ahead and do that it'll allow you to
customize eslint more than otherwise but
i'm going to go ahead and pick the
airbnb style guide
and the final thing i'm going to pick
here
is i want my config file to be json
and i want to go ahead and also make
sure i have all pure dependencies
installed
so once that's done running what we're
going to see on our left hand side in
the file tree
is a new file called eslintrc.json
and this has all the configurations that
we just talked about
it's the exact setup i had through all
those prompts
and now what i'm going to want to do is
speaking from experience is add in
eslint ignore file so i'm going to touch
dot eslint ignore
and eslint is automatically going to
lend some files i don't want linted
and the dot eslint ignore file is going
to make sure eslint ignores those
particular files that i specify so i'm
going to go ahead and add node modules
as a directory i don't want linted
src slash assets
and then the public directory
save that
and the final thing we want to do is
make sure eslint the extension is
installed
in my case i already have it installed
and after all that is done
you can go ahead and
reload
your window
and you're going to see eslint tick
effect
so what you immediately see here
is that there are a bunch of errors that
eslint has picked up on
and i'm going to go through and fix a
couple just to show how eastlint works
i'm going to go ahead and hover over
this first one which is on the snapshot
variable
it shows a brief visualization of what
the problem is you can also click view
problem
and it'll give an expanded message it
also shows the eslint rule
that is making this show up you can
click on this rule
and it'll open the browser to show you a
specification of what this rule exactly
is in eslint documentation
so now we see snapshot is never
reassigned use constant set okay that
makes sense so i want to fix this real
quick what's the way to do this well you
just hover over again
there's this quick fix option
you get a bunch of options here you
could fix all prefer const problems at
once which would take care of a lot of
the problems in this file you could fix
this one in particular you can disable
it so eslint just ignores this error for
once
you could show documentation for the
file and finally you could fix all
autofixable problems which would take
care of a lot of this file so in this
case i'm just going to fix this one
const problem
and immediately what we're going to see
is eslint changes this let to a const
and now that error is gone
now we'll go to the next one
hover over
quick fix this
and we'll just fix all auto fixable
problems
and you can see that most the errors are
gone
i know this seems a little messy right
now and that's just because i
bootstrapped the whole project
at once
but often linters are set up in the
beginning of the project so in practice
you would probably do a lot of this
during project setup and in real time
you would get these errors and you would
just fix them so generally the vs code
extension has allowed me to
pick and choose where to fix my problems
but also enforces best coding practices
like the ones i just showed you
the last extension i want to talk about
is docker docker is a containerization
platform that developers use to deliver
applications uniformly across multiple
environments now if you don't know much
about docker outside of this tutorial i
highly encourage you to learn more about
it before looking at the extension
because it just won't make a ton of
sense if you have docker downloaded
locally already you can go ahead and
install this extension as well and it's
published by microsoft and that's how
you're going to know you're installing
the right one
if you don't have docker installed
locally and you know how to use docker
be sure to download it from docker.com
and you'll be able to install by getting
started
once the extension is installed one of
the first things you'll notice is a new
icon on the left hand side
it's going to be one of the docker whale
and that's going to signify that you
have the installation at docker and
you're going to see this new left pane
on the side
that shows you various commands you can
run in docker before we get to this left
pane we're going to take a look at the
command palette because this is a place
where you can run a lot of docker
command that the extension powers so i'm
going to go ahead and load the command
palette up
and i'm going to type in docker
and what you're going to see
is many many docker commands you're
going to see a command to prune a
container a command to add docker files
to your workspace
a command to print the system and so on
and so forth
so what i want to do
is
generate a docker file for this repo
that i'm working on because i want to
containerize my application
so all i'm going to do is type in docker
and then files and i'm going to have two
options one to add docker files to my
workspace or one to add docker compose
files in this case i'm not working with
multiple containers i just want to
containerize this one repo and this one
application so i just want a single
docker file so i want to add docker
files to my workspace the first option
i'm going to click that now my
application is probably going to work on
a node.js application platform so that's
what i'm going to pick for my base image
here
i have a package.json file in my repo so
i'm going to pick that
i'm going to agree to port 3000
i do not want to include an optional
docker compose file because i don't need
it
and what we're going to see on the left
side when we open our tree is there's
going to be a newly generated docker
file here we see the docker ignore that
gets populated in and now we can click
the docker file
and we have a brand new docker file here
that should help us containerize
this application
we'll also notice if we interact with
this docker file that there's some
built-in intellisense using vs code's
native intellisense
basically if you go in this docker file
and you type in something like run which
is a docker command vs code's built-in
intellisense will pick up that this is a
docker command and it's going to show
you some documentation for that specific
command
which is really cool and really handy
all the time
now if we go back to the docker will
we're going to look at this pane on the
left hand side and the first thing we're
going to notice is that there's a
container running for me and that's just
the getting started container
that comes with the docker desktop app
what i'm going to do is stop this
container directly in my vs code editor
and when i'm hovering over it to do this
i get a better visualization of
information regarding this particular
container
including the name of the container the
image the ports it's running on and so
on and so forth i'm going to go ahead
and stop this by right clicking and then
pressing stop
and it's going to stop the container and
now what i can do is i can also
decide i want to prune this container i
don't even want to stop it i just want
to make sure it's completely gone to
clean up my setup
so i'm gonna go ahead and prune this
container in the command palette
it's gonna ask are you sure you want to
remove all stopped containers i'm gonna
say yes
and i've removed that getting started
container
now if you keep on looking at the left
pane you're going to see there's an
images options
in my particular case i only have the
getting started image and if you expand
the images
you're gonna get each image tag
i only have the latest tag and that's
why it's only showing a singular image
you could also set your extension up to
be synced with a registry
i'm synced with an azure registry many
people use aws and docker hub you can go
ahead and do that and basically what
they'll allow you to do is push docker
images straight to your registries from
vs code
and there's many more advanced features
that you can pull off here in vs code
using the docker vs code extension like
volumes and networks and so on and so
forth so it's really incredible how much
power vs code and the extension
particularly gives you with docker once
you have the docker extension installed
in your vs code editor you get built-in
intellisense with docker you get the
ability to stop and start containers
straight in the editor you get the
ability to set up multiple containers
using docker compose envious code and
you can also interact with your registry
without ever leaving vs code
so that's going to be it for this video
if you like this video please give it a
like and also be sure to subscribe to
free code camp there's always a variety
of content coming out and i've
personally learned a ton from it and
thanks for watching